you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
displaced because of climate change sky
news analysis reveals the
unequal impact of extreme weather events
around the world
less meat more veg how changing what we
eat
could help save the planet
and the designer using a very unusual
material to make fashion more
[Music]
sustainable
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions and we start today with the
extreme weather that's caused severe
flooding in germany
at least 44 people have died and more
than 70 are missing
after torrential rain hit parts of
western europe
although linking any single event to
global warming is complicated climate
change
does increase the frequency of extreme
weather events
and sky news analysis has found that the
impact of these disasters on people
isn't shared equally in 2020
weather-related events led to more than
30 million displacements around the
world where
people are forced from their homes at
least temporarily
the vast majority of these displacements
were caused by
severe storms and floods and nearly
two-thirds of disasters last year
were in china bangladesh india the
philippines and the united states
now in the u.s the richest country in
the world
500 americans per 100 000 were forced
from their homes at least temporarily
due to storm surges and wildfires
it shows even wealthy countries face the
threat of displacement and migration
due to climate change but sky news
analysis has found people from poorer
countries are
five times more likely to be displaced
because poorer countries are less able
to recover from disasters
governments lack the resources needed to
help prevent these events becoming
crises
and to cope with the aftermath now
somalia
is one of the nation's most vulnerable
to climate change
drought in 2017 caused nearly 900
000 displacements and floods caused by
extreme rainfall and a cyclone last year
forced a further million people from
their homes
now overall last year an average of
almost 20 000
displacements took place every time a
severe weather event occurred
in low-income countries compared with 4
000 displacements
in the wealthier nations so those are
the numbers
but what does that look like for those
affected here's our diplomatic editor
dominick wagon colorful
but squalid where thousands of somalis
are now forced to live
display sounds such a neutral term it
means being forced to give up your home
flee for your lives and end up somewhere
like this
like how osman abdi whose home was
washed away by floods
who's lost her husband and is now left
alone with
is
the same story in india with a cyclone
bringing floods in bengal
forcing many others to flee
there are climate driven weather
disasters in richer countries of course
five hurricanes in one year in this part
of louisiana
and devastating wild fires wreaking
havoc up and down the west of north
america
you'd expect the impact to be easier on
the first world more resources better
infrastructure
but the new figures revealed the extent
of that gulf
climate change uprooting five times as
many people in poorer nations and rich
even though developed nations can suffer
even more devastating weather
what is universal is the sense that
something is shifting
and in the wrong direction there's
something going on that's for sure man
because it's
one thing after another one thing after
another
and for millions and millions only
getting worse
dominic waghorn sky news
and you can read more about that
investigation by the sky news data and
forensics team
on our website skynews.com climate
let's take a look now at some of the
day's other climate news and the marine
conservation society is urging people to
take part
in this year's great british beach clean
volunteers will collect rubbish from
coastal areas across the uk
during the week-long campaign in
september seven out of ten
of the uk's dirtiest beaches are found
in scotland with king horn in
5 ranked top according to a new study by
save on energy more than 100 low-income
governments are demanding
clear action from wealthier countries
ahead of the cop 26 conference
in november the group want rich nations
to move faster to reduce their
greenhouse gas emissions
and provide 100 billion dollars a year
in climate finance
they say they're frustrated with the
slow progress at the recent g7 leader
summit and meetings of g20 groups
the international energy agency is
warning that renewables aren't expanding
quickly enough
to keep up with the global demand for
electricity the agency's latest report
suggests
global electricity will rise by 5 this
year
as economies recover from the pandemic
it estimates nearly half of the increase
will have to be met by burning fossil
fuels which could push carbon dioxide
emissions to record highs
and exmore's first baby beaver to be
born for centuries has been named after
the footballer
marcus rashford the national trust asked
the public to help choose a name for the
young beaver
after a clip of him went viral on social
media rashford was filmed at the
charity's holy cot estate in somerset
where the animals were reintroduced last
year
and a reminder that the weekly climate
show is out tomorrow and in this episode
the story of the 69 year old grandpa
turning
indonesia's mountains green and you can
watch that on sky new social channels
our app
and our website now less meat more fruit
and vegetables and even
algae will be needed on the menu if the
uk is to meet its climate targets
those are recommendations from the new
national food strategy
published today it says that farmers
should be helped to manage land to store
carbon
and millions of pounds invested in the
development of alternative proteins such
as lab-grown
meat well in a moment i'll be speaking
to the founder of a company making a
slaughter-free
sausage but first here's why meatless
meat could be better for the planet
[Music]
well joining me now is russ tucker
co-founder of ivy farm technologies a uk
lab grown meat company uh welcome to you
so tell us more about your work what is
cultured meat and a slaughter-free
sausage
hi anna so cultured meat is exactly the
same as real meat it's just made in a
different way
we start by taking a small sample of
cells from a living animal
such as a pig or a cow there's no
slaughter required at all
we put them in the right environment
which is a tank we call it a bioreactor
it's got the right nutrients for the
cells to multiply for them to grow
and two to three weeks later we harvest
our mints
from that reactor and we can make
delicious sausages delicious beef
burgers for people to enjoy
and explain to us why you say this is
better for the planet
well it's not just me but there's an
independent study completed recently
that said that if you use renewable
energy
to make cultured meat whatever meat that
is whether it's beef or whether it's
pork
then you can save on carbon emissions
but also on land use
so right now if you were to tuck into a
delicious half pound burger
is the equivalent of driving from london
to birmingham 23 kilos of co2
but with cultured meats it would just be
one kilo so you wouldn't even get
outside of london
and is it true that actually a shift
towards a purely
plant-based diet is at diet is actually
what's best for the planet
i think the reality is that people love
meat i mean
from the report today henry dimbleby's
report
we've seen that he considered a meat tax
but chose not to do it because
of britain's britain's love for the
great british banger
so we have to provide a solution to
consumers to give them the meat that
they really love
at a lower carbon emissions better land
use and i think
cultured meat is one of the answers so
when can we get slaughter-free sausages
on our plates
well our plan is to open an urban farm
in 2023 so we want consumers to come to
the site in london where they can meet
some of the animals that the cells have
been taken from and
to have a delicious sausage or delicious
burger
but by 2025 we want to be making 12 000
tons a year and that would save 173 000
pigs from slaughter
russ tucker thanks very much indeed
thanks
now the fashion and clothing industry
has a huge impact on the environment
but one designer is trying to do her bit
to change that
meet alice potts who makes biodegradable
materials out of everything
from sweat to petals
not only design but biology to create
new materials which actually are fully
sustainable and biodegradable
my first um material that i focused on
developing
was sweat crystallization this was a
method that i worked alongside with
imperial college
of collecting people's sweat and
extracting out
basically the sodiums the lactic acids
and
the estrogen to make these bio crystals
which were then embellished onto these
fashioned
materials i also developed firebase
plastics unlike most bio plastics which
are available in market
is made 100 from natural ingredients
so mine is a base of different things
like seaweed
flowers and natural earth i first went
into making biodegradable face shields
because
one of the issues that i'd always had
with my bio-based plastics was
they didn't have the longevity of
plastics because of
clothing there was a mass increase of
single-use plastics
being discarded so for me it seemed like
a great opportunity to
have a material which didn't have a
longevity of plastic that could degrade
back into the earth the more
that we start understanding about
natural materialization and
understanding about the earth
is for me the best way that we're
actually going to start becoming
more sustainable
[Music]
well that's everything from us for today
next time the underrated
climate superheroes find out how sharks
can help restore
damaged ecosystems that's tomorrow here
on the daily climate show
see you then
you